hasta hace un mes vital sum diseñada
aprendas peta aporte que vendía francia
españa o italia y participaban desfiles
de moda ahora en su taller de costura ha
puesto a las modistas a coser chalecos
antibalas para las tropas ucranianas
me inscribí como voluntario en el
ayuntamiento y me pidieron que hiciera
chalecos porque es lo que más necesitan
nuestros soldados y los voluntarios de
fuerzas de defensa territoriales
mixtas
pero cambiar la producción en el taller
de confección no fue sencillo tanto por
la falta de materiales como los diseños
al principio fue bastante complicado
necesitábamos unas telas mucho más
gruesas y las agujas eran demasiado
finas y se rompían muchas veces pero
estoy contenta de ayudar a nuestros
soldados yo acá
este rojo medio
la confección casera de chalecos
antibalas se ha convertido en una de las
mayores necesidades para el ejército
desde forjadores para separar láminas de
metal de manistas y militares retirados
como leds se han puesto a fabricar las
placas anti fragmentación
no me dejaron ir al ejército porque soy
muy mayor así que lo único que podía
hacer es aplicar mi experiencia militar
para confeccionar placas balísticas de
diferentes niveles el interviú son los
derviches el de otro gusto pues tuviera
el 9 en brno y plate la ciudad portuaria
de esa se ha blindado ante un ataque
inminente ruso con barricadas de sacos
de arena obstáculos anti tanques y por
último con la confección de chalecos
antibalas